[Music]  you pincher cheese bring back  [Music]  make the world  [Music]  friendly love here let's you it's item  [Music]  drafty  stoic eyes  [Music]  try to be  make it go they fade son sometimes  carry on regardless  so you guess  [Music]  try to leave  don't give the game away here is strong  one just carry on and no one needs to  know honey science  [Music]  [Applause]  boys  [Music]  to go along  it's not in fair  there's some shaky ground and we're  guilty you know just because creatures  trying to save  cherry pies make a guy leave night  carry on regardless  yes by it  try to be brave don't get  you're strong one just carry on No  holy science  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  make it go  carry on  won't yes  try to be brash give the game away  you're a strong one just carry on  no sir sadness  [Laughter]  [Music]  [Music]